he saved a lot of lives by doing that
the media did not cover the story
we are proud to have raul mendes join us
tonight uh mr mendez thanks so much for
coming on it's an unbelievable story i'm
amazed that you were willing to to tell
it here and grateful that you are can
you tell us what exactly happened
yeah thank you so much so
actually the family and i were invited
to you know friends gathering july 3rd
and we were having a great time and an
uninvited neighbor made his way inside
the house and unprovoked just started
opening fire at all of us
first victim was carl you know he was
shot and just died instantly
as i heard the first gunshot you know i
turned
and he was able to catch me in the right
side of my head
bullet went through and took on my left
eye
as this was happening the gunman just
continued his killing spree he went
towards you know the people in the
living room
where he uh you know took out another
good friend just shot him in the top of
the head
uh right after this
uh the shooter actually made his way to
the master bedroom where two brave women
physically fought the gunman
uh one of my good friends was actually
shot three four times in the arm once in
the leg and she still was able to gather
the strength and the willpower to
wrestle him off
she was able to grab his arm and fire
the remaining shots he had in his
magazine
and just you know shoot him on the floor
and in the air and not shoot anybody
else
that's when the gunman realized you know
he's out of ammunition on that pistol so
he actually decides to just grab her and
try to finish her off by choking her
while another brave friend that was
hiding with two children
in the
master closet came out with a rifle that
she couldn't load but she actually uses
it to strike them in the head so as
they're striking them they're able to
you know beat them pretty bad and giving
me the opportunity to actually get up
from a you know headshot wound
and pull out my own firearm and you know
eliminate the threat right then and
there
i mean
i'm stunned by the story you just told i
mean it doesn't even sound real i know
that it is real um so with your eye shot
out you were able
to to eliminate the gunman to shoot the
gunman yeah how uh
where did you serve the military are you
a police officer
i did not i have no professional
training
honestly i just feel like my body just
went into autopilot did what any father
friend
husband would do and just you know
protect his own and like i said just
auto pilot kicked in and
i think just you know god just wanted me
to be there to protect my family and
friends and
honestly i'm just very thankful
i'm thankful to be here today and also
thankful for my two friends that
actually were able to bring down the
gunman and give me the opportunity to do
what i had to do to protect everybody
i i don't know why you're not the most
famous man in america i mean that's just
that's a heroic story your description
of it is really moving sincerely as a
father i feel that way and god bless you
for what you did and for your composure
and your ability to describe it so thank
you roe mendes
really thank you for having me thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight